as we squeezed its heart will make it
harder for ISIL to pump its terror and
propaganda to the rest of the world this
fall
even before the revolting attacks in
Paris and San Bernardino I ordered new
actions to intensify our war against
ISIL these actions including more
firepower and special operations forces
are well underway
this continues to be a difficult fight
as I said before ISIL is dug in
including in urban areas and they hide
behind civilians we are hitting ISIL
harder than ever
coalition aircraft our fighters bombers
and drones have been increasing the pace
of airstrikes nearly 9,000 as of today
we're going after ISIL from their
stronghold right down right in downtown
Raqqa
to Libya where we took out Abu Nabil the
ISIL leader there the point is ISIL
leaders cannot hide and our next message
to them is simple you are next in many
places isil's lost its freedom of
maneuver because they know if they mask
their forces we will wipe them out
in fact since this summer ISIL has not
had a single successful major offensive
operation on the ground in either Syria
or Iraq so far ISIL has lost about 40%
of the populated areas at once
controlled in Iraq and it will lose more
isil's lost thousands of square miles of
territory at once controlled in Syria
and it will lose more the Special Forces
that I ordered to Syria begun supporting
local forces they push south cut off
supply lines and tighten the squeeze on
Raqqa meanwhile more people are seeing
ISIL for the thugs and the thieves and
the killers that they are we've seen
instances of ISIL fighters defecting
others who've tried to escape have been
executed and isil's reign of brutality
and extortion continues to repel local
populations and help fuel the refugee
crisis so many people are migrating said
one Syrian refugee ISIL she said will
end up all alone this holiday season
many of our troops are once again far
from their families and as your
commander in chief on behalf of the
American people we want to say thank you
we are grateful and we are proud for
everything that you do because of you
the America that we know and love and
cherish is leading the world in this
fight because of you I am confident that
we are going to prevail thank you very
much everybody